MH welcome Leon to the studio I mean
this game was really interesting as all
your games against Maxim I think you
were fighting all the time and have very
good positions what can you tell about
this opening Choice today and what
happened uh yeah I think we were trying
to surprise each other uh and uh maybe I
managed to surprise him slightly more
with Queen D5 it's uh it's a little bit
of a rare
move um I think I think black is
basically asking white to take on F6 and
play Knight D2 uhh that's more or less
the what would happen if if white will
do so yeah it's a I mean it's it's a
playable position for black I think
black needs to take and then Ed KN C6
something like that is but you know um
if if you are not remembering the
correct way to play for white then
having those C3 uh D4 Pawns is not a
great joy I just remembered that like uh
here you need to play Knight
C6 and yeah black is fine so on Knight
C4 King E7 something like that yeah and
Bishop C4 Queen G2 so it's not possible
to take with the bishop otherwise it
would be nice and I also remember that
here this bishop
A7 there are many ways for black to play
I thought Knight C6 I thought during the
game that it makes a lot of sense I just
develop and you know try to play Rook C8
so you were happy with about your
position I thought it's a playable
position and we discussed with you now
nowadays if we got the playable position
it's already good news absolutely
absolutely and then so after Rook b85
this uh happened I think you know I I I
felt that maybe it should be slightly
tiny bit more comfortable for me to play
but uh yeah somehow it all you know
depends on details so for example exle
this was more or less logical what
happened so F1 okay Knight F5 I thought
maybe I can play with F6 but I thought
Knight F5 is principal in fact my
intention was to meet D5 with F4 but
then I kind of
um got uh yeah I think um after I
saw some things I wasn't so sure anymore
because yeah Knight D4 is coming and if
I play let's say here I didn't like G4 M
you know he's undermining my Bishop's
position so I'm not in time uh to to
lock the bishop in so then I told to
myself all right I will do the same
thing just a little bit later when the
moment arises and yeah so this is what
actually happened I mean after Bishop G3
uh yes here Bishop G3 yeah King F7
Knight D2 Rook C8 this is all very
logical and uh yeah F4 I think is a good
move because I kind of Play Bishop to F5
and then just play G4 and structurally I
always have this maneuver with a knight
to D6 for example if white block yeah if
white does something like let's say Rook
D1 G4 Knight F1 yeah I don't have to
worry much I just bring the Knight and
and then C4 Pawn will be always yeah
yeah and I think black black should be
fine here so and then uh so I think we
both understood that the position is
more or less equal and the game went to
its natural uh path on on the natural
path yeah I mean I mean so here King F2
when he played um oh yeah kinging first
he played yes King F2 then he decided to
I mean first king of one then King of2
was the idea probably to move the Knight
yes yes yes like maybe that was the last
trick he tried to in this game
know yeah but but okay you didn't let
him yeah because now Knight F1 uh is met
with this and now if he goes this six no
wait sorry not Bishop C4 Knight C4 and I
think this6 doesn't work because I can
take this oops check yeah King G1 Rook e
one and King G3 Rook e six Rook e six
wow two pieces are hanging yes so
everybody calculated everything and the
game finished in the end eventually
finished in the draw how did it feel for
you to play today same same playing hole
as us CH Championship but different
event so was it any difference well it's
always interesting to play against Maxim
you know he's always fighting so I uh
he's one of the players that uh I like
playing against because he's he's giving
chances and he's uh you know he's one of
those guys that uh are um not settling
for uh just uh boring games that's for
sure yes so it was a very fighting draw
today thank you so much Leon and all the
best in the next rounds thank you thank
you Anastasia thank you leavon coming up